literally did that when you walked in
you're like [__] you Dad and you hung up
dude no no no no my oh my God why you
got to do that what did I miss what did
I
[Music]
miss and welcome back to another Stellar
episode of the careful boys and today we
have Giani here
hey Rock going rly okay we're going to
get deep okay in your butthole all right
what single event again I'm sorry toize
you're an [__] okay here we go what
single event or decision do you think
most affected the rest of your life and
was there a turning point in your
life I told you it was
deep um yeah when I moved to Los
Angeles yeah when did you move to LA uh
on my 19th birthday oh really yeah when
we met and you were like producing uh
with at the time how old were you then
22 wow 22 oh so you were like when you
moved out here how many years until you
started working in the industry was it
immediately yeah immediately I got like
an agent and started auditioning but
like um I'd say about 22 was really like
when I started 2122 was like took me a
couple years to like get into it but um
yeah I was playing I was a hockey player
my whole life and I was you know drafted
in a semi-professional league and you
know I had college offers and I was like
I don't want to do this anymore I knew
that when I was young I knew what I
wanted to do but when I like made the
decision to move out here and never play
hockey again like that was like a a
total left field Turning Point like
everyone's like what the [__] like but I
just I mean it's like from athleticism
to acting it's still entertainment right
it's not like you went like engineer
yeah or something do I look like do I
look like an engineer dude you could be
an engineer bro of what you know
mechanical stuff I think I don't think
so you look like you could be a blue
color worker in the
factory yeah if I cover all the bling
cover the [__] ice dude and add a
uniform for yeah was that a hard
decision to make to move clear across
the country I just wanted to do it I I
actually dude I it was not hard at all I
just couldn't wait to do it like oh
you've been you've been needing to so
it's like the second I got here it's
like when um it's like what he feels
when he gets to an airport he's
like like me I'm like dude I'm here baby
was that something you always wanted to
do like all your life it was in the back
of your head or was there okay mhm there
you go see I envy that what want doing
something that you always wanted to do
since a kid don't you always do what you
want to do yeah but I don't have like
one thing I have like 20 things so it's
spread throughout so many things what a
problem yeah that's even better what you
have all these goals [__]
you and then I can't do any of them good
shut the [__]
up that's a good one that's a good one
moving to that's that's a huge that's
probably so many other people's dreams
you know what I mean the idea of being
like yo I want to pursue my one dream
and maybe it takes uprooting their
entire life and and going to La is kind
of a very Hollywood cliche but at the
same time but he did it f yeah that's
huge crazy how like we don't have to
work so hard for some something because
we grew up right next to it yeah yeah
and other people come here well we got
to think think about our parents
immigrating that's totally different
they they had the different coming to La
version you know what I mean they're not
actors so I don't
care my my parents have not been any
movies bro my dad wasn't in good luck
tomorrow what the [__] is that we should
lecture our parents on like dude you
traveled all the way to America you
wasted away working at this shitty job
yeah you couldn't try to be an actor
what the [__] yeah and it's funny cuz
your dad's in entertainment my parents
had a music school wait your dad is
isn't he was a sound engineer he was
like a sound but he did all the biggest
movies though yeah his his uh
filmography is pretty crazy does he
still do it no he's at the game but he
started like he started working the mail
room Indiana at like at like Paramount
or something and then he just worked his
way up and then became a sound does he
have some crazy have you had him on here
you think he was like moving the mail
cart and just like making sound effects
and somebody was like this fool he came
home from school and there was Keo
Reeves just sitting on his couch you
know the guy from The Matrix you just
saw that movie he took a piss in my
bathroom really dude did you save it you
cued it he flushed it he flushed it he
knew he a [__] veteran he knew you
were going to go for it he sniffing
around dude what that's you should have
your dad on the show and don't bring up
[__] ever just have him on and talk
cool stories we're going to bring up
[__] have him react to the video
yeah he'll probably bring it up you say
to him you're like Dad who would you
[__] me or my
brother and that was the 17th call back
in one video yeah dude I got enough of
the call backs no it's fine now the
people know they know what's your
question again what's the biggest
pivotal moment in your life something
about [__] I forget uh what single
event or decision do you think most
affected the rest of your life and what
was a turning was there a turning point
in your life biggest affect of your life
dude life the biggest oh mine's easy
what is it mine is when I said [__] you
to my parents oh didn't you do like 12
times no like a real one though you
literally did that when you walked in
you're like [__] you Dad and you hung up
dude no no no
no oh my God why you got to do that
mine's a uh this one's a real [__] you
cuz like I think like what did I miss
what did I miss my dad's not alive a
hisult it's his fault it's his fault
what did he do it was a Steve call back
it was a Steve call back you know what I
mean it's a bit but anyways what were
you saying Bart so like growing up like
in school I think in my brain I've been
uh I've been trying to be a good kid and
been trying to go okay this is what my
parents want for me so even though I did
get in a lot of trouble and stuff it was
still like let me try to get back on the
track of what my parents want for me
what did they want you what did they
want for you be
[Laughter]
and then in college me and Joe started
doing uh JK films I was like dude this
is like the first time that I'm like
making decisions for myself and I really
enjoy this and even then I still didn't
really have the confidence to go you
know what I'm just going to go YouTube
full-time and kind of like take my life
into my own hands it was still like okay
what do my parents want me to do and
I've kept trying to find this compromise
and then when I graduated I just
realized you can't really have a
compromise kind of like with the LA
thing right you can't live on the east
and west coast you got to go like what
am I going to do and I was like you know
what I've done or I've tried to do what
they wanted me to do my whole life and
it's made me very unhappy I'm just going
to go try to do something that makes me
100% happy and then that's when I was
like all right [__] this both me and Joe
got part-time jobs and then from that
point on I remember like we were the
really really broke but I was happy
every [__] day cuz every decision was
made by me and even if it backfired it
was because I made it for me so it
wasn't like you make a decision and if
you made it for someone else if it
backfires you kind of hate the other
person you know well it's because you
made me do this but now it's like
everything was on me and I think that
was the biggest turning point for like
the way I viewed the rest of my life I'm
like dude I'm just going to keep start
doing every single thing that makes my
gut feel excited and I'm going to keep
pursuing that and I was like the the
biggest thing and then now I can't wait
to rub it in one of my parents face
every single day
yeah follow that one up Nick Nick's like
oh when I did Jiu-Jitsu it was
cool [__] how did you know my thing dude
how did you know it was my thing that is
a Nick answer oh [__] he goes when I
first submitted someone uh I thought
that was
sick wait what's what's with the hand I
don't know yeah I don't do that with my
hands I know your hands just kind of
look like that I
you D dude well I can't go now because
the already went for me I can't I can't
stop someone stop me I don't want to
actually is that is that the new Nick
impression yeah uh well like that oh
well jiujitsu blank I feel like me me
and my friend always do that to each
other like when we Mak it funny each
other so just scks it just sticks got
that Raptor arm dude my strong hand yeah
so Nick so he's thinking he's thinking
the first time I did
jiu-jitsu anything other than but
honestly it's so [__] funny but for
me um I think it was there I'm not going
to say there was one [__] main thing
right there's always at every stage of
my life there was this one point where I
was really conflicted by something and I
had to make a decision and you go and
you kind of eat [__] for a little bit
and then you figure it out and I think
that was what was really important for
me um for me when I first started when I
first started fighting and I wanted to
be a fighter and I was like dude I'm
going to be [__] so good dude I'm
going to be [__] sick the first 6
months of me training was the hardest
[__] thing I've ever had to do going
from where I was which
was mentally I wasn't there physically I
wasn't there so I was going through a
big change in everything I did my
routine I was in pain all the time and I
was like dude this is I don't know if I
could do this and that was like the
first hard part was like the first month
I was like dude I was eating [__] I was
getting beat up all the time and I just
felt like there was no success
for the first like 3 4 months so for me
it was having to deal with all that [__]
and then being like well I made it this
far I might as well just keep going what
made you stick it through because I knew
that I was like this is what I want to
do I know I want to do this but this is
so [__] hard and I I was battling
every day single day to go train or do
anything physical was a battle for me
mentally and I felt like I did it on
Monday I got to do it again on Tuesday
and I just
today's video is brought to you by
Uncommon Goods you know what's dope
about Uncommon Goods what a lot of times
during the holiday season you're like
what should I buy but everything's
played the [__] out go to the same
stores all the time you're going to get
that wax sweater you're going to get
that caramel popcorn that no one's going
to eat and it's going to just turn stale
in the pantry it's going to stay there
till next Christmas and that's why I
like Uncommon Goods cuz they got all
these unique independent small
businesses with cool stuff with awesome
gift ideas we got the Mochi donut kit
right here Yep this is actually my first
time opening it look at this wow you can
make your own Mochi donut and it's
signed by Mr M moto himself support
small businesses guys anything white in
a bag like this makes me happy every
purchase you make they give $1 to a
nonprofit of your choice so not only do
you have a good time with your family
get a unique gift and you help the world
to get 15% off your next gift go to
uncommongoods.com
offthe that's
uncommongoods.com sloff theere for 15%
off don't miss out on this limited time
offer un common goods cuz we're all out
of the ordinary there was days where I
would just not show up the train I just
wouldn't go I would avoid it completely
but I felt so [__] bad and I felt
like I was letting myself down so I was
like well that was the only main
motivation for me to move forward
because I felt so shitty about myself
but at the same time every time I did
that I over I I prove to myself that
like okay I could do this I didn't think
I could do this 3 months ago but now I'm
6 months in so I might as well just keep
going and just keep tripping away and
then that was like the big moment for me
and then later in my career was like
when I left the gym that I was at for
like 10 years so it was everything wow
my business was tied into it so me
leaving that was like really scar
what the [__] I was going to do I
thought I was going to be poor and
during the same time I actually moved in
with Tiff and I got engaged that year
which was kind of crazy so a lot of like
big stuff that happened for me that kind
of had to prove myself that like okay I
could I could be an adult I could go
through some hard [__] and be okay so
that was like my version of that so yeah
I guess Jiu-Jitsu is a big part of
that sorry dude I didn't know I godam
put your hands right here yeah do the
hand thing so jju was a good time for me
follow that oh you already went damnn it
yeah Colleen mine was I had a really bad
injury when I was dancing um in my like
early te 20s and that was a catalyst for
me to explore other avenues as far as
what I wanted to do professionally so I
went into production so editing picked
up a camera then started directing and
now I have a production company so if it
wasn't for that injury I wouldn't had
explored other op is it cuz you were
pursuing dance and then you didn't have
any other thing that you were looking to
kind of yeah yeah yeah what what was the
injury I ripped my hamstring in a half
during a performance no [__] way
during a performance oh [__] and then
when you hear the whole audience just go
and then you're on the floor and you're
like oh this is me and I have like maybe
like four eight counts left and you're
just trying to get up and do like just
the the arm choreography and then
curtain's closing you're like [__] this
doesn't feel right wait can you give me
more details just because I'm curious
like what what was the performance like
what was the it was actually in high
school oh [__] so what kind of was it
like Grease the musical or
something it was exactly gree musical
was it like Conan the Tango version or
yeah no it was a we had a um take us
back we had a dance performance for the
whole school um so we had different so
there were like different tiers of
people in the class that we had so like
beginners or intermediates your advance
and we would put on a showcase for the
school kind of like a recital correct
and then kind of like that and then um I
had maybe eight different pieces in the
the Showcase and it was the seventh one
and we were doing like a a trick that we
had done countless times no problems the
girl that lifted me this time she was
off by like maybe a half count and just
pulled my leg at the wrong time what was
her name first last name yeah what's she
doing right now she's [__]
loser what if she Nancy carrian you and
she's a star now because she was the
lead in Greece okay it wasn't me dang
what a good play though like I was her
like that's a good move accelerator
career and then I just remember dropping
to the floor I hear a pop first drop to
the floor hear the audience and I'm like
oh [__] like did something happen I'm
like oh it's me did it hurt like
immediately or no the adrenaline kicked
in enough to where you don't feel it um
you just in in your mind you just go
just get through it just get through it
um and then when you get off stage
that's when the pain really hits oo that
was pretty so you continued the dance
yeah were you wobbling around cuz you
were like injured oh you just went
through the
wow The Show Must Go On dang that's
crazy like how long did that push you
out I was on crutches my whole sit in
your ear dang a fully torn hamstring
fully torn like from the back of my
kneecap all the way to the bottom of my
butt fully ripped damn that's like a
rubber band that snapped and you were
like mentally you were like I want to
pursue dance as a career that's crazy
that must have been devastating yeah it
was like a whole identity you you're not
a dancer though cuz like look at all the
dancers like they're not really going
anywhere I know it was best decision
ever man you got saved right yeah but if
you think about it like as high as you
can get as a dancer is kind of like
touring with a big artist and that's
probably one of them oh my God am I
wrong let him go am I wrong just let him
go like the highest you get his Dan is
like touring with with an artist it's
tough it's tough in the new generation
the highest you can go in general is
getting to JK
news which is pretty [__] low out
there
hey hey hey you could work on Circ look
at the end of the day we're all in the
same place this is like when like the
smartest kid at your school and you
still end up in the same college and
you're like haha didn't [__] matter
did it and then after you all get the
same tattoo too yep sure also true and
now you can't escape so we're all at the
same plan valid dictorian
[__] damn damn that's crazy yeah but if
it wasn't for that who knows it's always
like that though right where like
something is like you think it's a
tragedy and it's a catalyst to something
else and you're like wait I found my
true love well it felt like that for a
while right until you start exploring
like okay well what else is there what
made you go like editing like it was
like um well I couldn't do anything like
athletic at the time oh you need
something that you could just sit down
so the I had met people who were filming
a lot of dance and music videos at the
time and for me being a dancer I was
like oh I get I just don't know the
tools to execute the thoughts that I had
in my mind in the editing program so
learning that was like okay I could
build the bridge between knowing dance
and making sure that it's executed the
proper way and then editing those types
of projects I see and then that just
kind of led into everything else did you
do it on Final Cut uh no I I started on
Premier oh okay started on Premier
started old school that's cool CS that's
crazy then once my leg started to heal I
was like I'm I can't sit here for like
10 hours editing it's not [__] for me
so I put the camera if you're active
person it's like I need to move and then
I get even more crazier if I don't move
which is why dping is so much more
you're more in the action doing like
stunts and filming stunts now and stuff
like that you're like you take the
footage and edit it yeah you got to pay
someone I'll record it so I'm just
like making noises the whole time
they're like they can hear the noises
stop doing that no I got to add it I got
to add it we add that in
later damn what about you Anthony Lee
did we ask you yet um yeah probably it
all all comes down to after our first
you know technical kindas performance we
call the U Black Ops at the time that
was when I was quitting Dancing and I
was going to move to Arizona for my
sales job uh and then what year was this
this is 2010 Dam you were going to quit
Dancing I told you before no I just
remember you were going to quit to
become a you a YouTube dance group I
thought you were going to quit your job
never said that I remember that oh yeah
well yeah I was I was working a sales
job in like 2009 and 2010 after college
and then I was getting promoted so I was
going to get my own office in Arizona so
I hit up Mike song and I was like Yo
dude uh I'm about to quit Dancing cuz
I'm about to move out of state so let's
let's get down together one last time
and we had never really gotten down
together especially in like uh with all
of our homies cuz we always competed
against each other so we're like all
right [__] it let's do it and he like
postponed all of his jobs and stuff cuz
he had just come off the heels of ABDC
Season 1 with cabba and so he he was
[__] doing he was the man he was
doing the thing you know what I mean um
and just traveling everywhere so he just
was like all right I'll chill out on
jobs for the month and then we'll prep a
show and that show was the entire thesis
of that show the entire premise of it
was just do everything we always wanted
to do so it was like a [__] college
boy like we we brought all of our like
fraternity College homies who don't even
dance on stage cuz we're like yo you
want to get on stage we drank on stage
we wanted to smoke on stage but then and
our homie who runs the show was like no
that's a fire hazard so can't do that so
we just danced Cuz I Got High um and we
like kind of jacked off on stage his a
whole thing um point is circle jerk big
old circle jerk big old Circle sick dude
you join next time but uh we do this
show as like a like kind of like the
martini glass end off but afterwards it
was the craziest Standing Ovation I've
still to this day ever gotten in my life
it was the best performance still to
this day like best feeling ever and that
Thursday I went and I basically quit my
job I'm not [__] leaving I'm not
[__] leaving yeah that is a huge like
pivotal moment I'm not [__] leaving
hands down the biggest moment were the
standing ovations because all the guys
had their pants around their ankles and
they were had a bone or two so as a
standing that we and it was impressive
yeah um but no that you know like Bart
it's like when you make a decision even
though you don't necessarily have or
know the runway but you're just like I'm
going to start making these calls for
myself you know what I mean
like it wasn't like the more stable or
like you know traditional route of doing
something and it was like actually if
anything frowned upon and not really
accepted version that like your you know
your peers or your your parents might
understand but you're like [__] it I got
to do this because there's something
weird about like ending the thing I love
and beginning the thing I don't love you
know what I mean mhm that's tight thank
you for sharing that's pretty good that
was the same year I ripped my hamstring
oh [__]
oh really what year is this 2010 damn
that was the year I started training
dude wow that was the year I started at
high school [__] you get the [__] out of
here
[Music]
dude